so there's a question that came in and
they wanted to know should they be
concerned about Gaucho genic foods okay
so what is a goitrogenic food it's a
food that can cause a goiter an enlarged
thyroid so the thyroid is right in the
base of your neck about two and a half
inches wide and it can swell up if it
doesn't have I identified ein well the
thyroid then is not going to be able to
send the signal back up to pituitary and
that is going to cause more thyroid
stimulating hormone to be produced and
that's coming down from the pituitary to
the thyroid and as two functions one is
to release more thyroid hormone and
there were two to enlarge the thumb
right so it's gonna get bigger so what
foods can potentially create these
effects cassava corn cabbage which is
part of the cruciferous vegetables that
will include like kale broccoli brussel
sprouts bok choy etc then we have canola
soy beans almonds cherries strawberries
spinach sweet potato and there are many
more as well now right off the bat I'm
gonna recommend not to consume sweet
potato anyway so you can rule that out
and not to do canola cuz this GMO and
not to do corn or cassava or soy beans
okay and cherries are a bit too high in
sugar and out of these foods cruciferous
could potentially be a problem but
really only for those people that are
sensitive to it also you'd have to
consume large amounts of cruciferous
frequently to create a deficiency also
realize that when you cook courser
Fereshteh Buhl's fermented boil it or
steam it you reduce these chemicals that
can create this effect so for most
people they don't have to worry about it
if you're concerned if you already have
a hypothyroid problem if you know you
have an iodine deficiency and you're
sensitive to these foods then take seek
help okay and don't consume these foods
on a daily
basses have them periodically but not
very often I also realize that one of
the best sources of iodine would be
shellfish fish and seek help now you
just want to make sure when you take
seek out don't take large and large
amounts all you need to do is one or two
in the morning and you're good to go and
that will give you enough iodine to
protect you from any potential
deficiency that any of these could
create alright thanks for watching if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos